hey wassup guys my name is a Turner and
welcome to 2017 so this video is just
here to be kind of like an update video
for the entire year just telling you
guys what I have planned has been a
while since I put out a video I think
about two months almost three months
probably and I mean I just want to tell
you guys what's been going on and what
the plan is for the year and hopefully
we'll see what we can do here so first
of all the hair the hair is gone new
year new me that's how I usually roll so
2017 hopefully is gonna be pretty pretty
sweet year but ultimately the things
that I want to talk about is this
YouTube channel because I haven't been
active at all lately and there are a few
reasons for that but basically I do want
to get back into this as usual it's a
new year I want to start fresh and I
want to hopefully have this year to be
an actual significant year in terms of
my youtube channel because in the past
year or so I haven't really done
anything new I haven't really really
grown or anything like that and I feel
that you guys are expecting content for
me that I'm not delivering and there's
all all that going on and and hopefully
we can work something out where I can
actually start making videos that you
guys want and hopefully I'll be able to
discipline myself into actually making
those videos instead of just lying
around doing nothing so of course just
so you guys know I am I do have a job
I'm a full-time software engineer yay
the studio here called fire monkeys but
I'm more or less in like kind of the
central engine division of AAA now
so we basically work on the game engine
behind pretty much every every a mobile
game that's coming out or at around
about now so that's what I do that's
like my full-time job obviously that
that's what my priorities lie so
obviously I don't have as much time to
do huge it as if I was like a full-time
youtuber or something so you guys have
to expect that that's the first thing I
want to kind of be real about the second
part though is that I do enjoy
programming and I love working on side
projects and stuff like that which is
where this comes in and I also really
love teaching so what's gonna happen is
hopefully I'm gonna get back to my style
of actually teaching and creating videos
that'll like tutorials rather than
actually the past you know a few things
that I've been doing where basically
I've had Sparky and those dev logs where
that's just been like hey check out all
the stuff that I'm doing
and obviously that's more of like an
update and more like a showcase rather
than actual here's how you can do is the
similar similar thing and then the other
the other series that I've had was the
the Genesis series which of course was
just me looking back on my old games and
fixing things and that was okay that
lasted for a while like I says I think
there's six or so episodes of that I
didn't really go anywhere with that I
might still continue to do that every
now and then but I'm realizing that it's
kind of not exactly the content that you
guys want to see or not necessarily as
useful to you as as I might have thought
that it would have been so more or less
it's it's it's you know I kind of missed
making those tutorial videos and I do
want to get back to that because that's
kind of what I started my channel with
so the things that I do have planned
I've got two series planned that I'm
going to hopefully run concurrently I'm
kind of interleaved and we'll definitely
talk about that in a minute now first of
all I want to address a comment here
that I read by a Caleb Miller right it's
gonna be on the screen I'm not gonna
read all of it here but you guys can
read it if you want and it's real like
it's it's kind of it's a real comment
right it's one of those like hey man I'm
being real with you and I like comments
like this I really do because I mean
this is I don't have as much time to
spend on YouTube as I'd like and this
isn't something that I can just sit down
and brainstorm with my team or something
and be like okay this is what we need to
do right this is kind of like hey I have
an idea and I pop it out there you guys
have to realize this right like YouTube
isn't my job and the amount I make from
YouTube is a gink is very very small so
I don't I do it for fun really like if
we're being real here like I'm doing ID
I started doing this for fun I'm doing
it for fun now it's nothing to do with
like hey let's make this video because
it's gonna bring in more money or
something like that I'm more or less
just make videos that I enjoy making it
has always kind of been like that and
which is why you might see me be a bit
kind of sporadic in a bit random with
the videos I put out and that's because
hey like on that day I felt like making
this video and this day I felt like
making this video and obviously for me
it's like hey I can put out a video and
people can watch it and hopefully enjoy
it and a lot of you guys are like that
but all
for those of you who actually kind of
take the seriously and you're like well
I want to become a software engineer I
want to become a game programmer how do
I do that like this channels becoming
less and less of a of a place for you
guys to actually learn how to do all
that so the cool thing yeah like
essentially I do want to get back to the
old kind of style and I've got two
series ideas that I'm going to kind of
pitch to you guys and then we'll see
what happens I am gonna make both of
them at the same time probably expect
like one Episode a week or something
like that
right there's no way I'm gonna be able
to do anything more than that but
hopefully I'll have time to do this but
basically the first series I want to do
is a C++ series right I've never done a
programming language series on my
youtube channel I think it'd be cool to
put together like a little a series in
which I talk about how to actually write
code in C++ especially because a lot of
people do it incorrectly and I mean I've
been I've been using I've been you know
writing C++ code professionally for just
over two years now and with the
particular with a particular kind of I
guess importance towards optimization
and writing fast code because of course
I work on the engine team and game
engines needs to be very very fast but
because of that like I feel like there's
a lot of kind of misconceptions about
C++ and there's a lot I can really bring
to the table in terms of hey this is how
your heightened property loss loss
especially in the context of game
programming because that's a bit
different than other software especially
when you have people like to say plus
plus kind of committee who have course
don't really care particularly much
about speed or optimization and they're
more or less in the game of hey this
should look nice or this should like
let's just like you know make this API
kind of extensible and they're more or
less in in the kind of let's make this
easier to program or let's make this
more powerful but they don't really care
too much about performance which is a
problem and why a lot of people actually
end up why a lot of game studios
actually end up replacing C++ as core
libraries with their own because it's
just not it's not not really good for
games or anything like that so
Cybil spots within it with like a kind
of focus on game development I think
it's quite a unique kind of experience
and I'm not 100% sure how I'll put that
series together but in terms of that
series they're like I feel like a good
way to put that together would be a
little bit snappier than my other videos
so maybe a few al throw in a few edits I
ha I could spend like a week producing a
video but the problem with that is the
first of all like I I don't like making
videos like I don't like editing videos
I never have that's actually the reason
why I stopped being a filmmaker I used
to be a filmmaker I used to do like
freelance film and stuff like that and I
actually wanted to be like a film
director or a film producer as like my
uh my film I don't mean like necessarily
like a future film I mean like any kind
of video really like you know ad
advertising music video stuff like that
anything like really I wanted to be a
producer and director for that but I
just hated editing so much that I
basically just decided hey you know what
is like kind of film but maths as well
game development and then I kind of got
into that but anyway and this I'm not
here to tell you guys my life story so
the idea is that I don't like editing
and because of that a lot I love the
kind of lives live style videos right
where I can just kind of sit in front of
a camera for about 30 minutes or a bunch
of code talk about a bunch of things and
they'll just put that on YouTube that
works for me but that's also really
annoying because 30 watching 30 minutes
on a topic that could be explained in
five minutes is really annoying and I I
know when I watch other people and I
just want to know one thing I have to
watch a 30 minute video it's great if
you know me and it's great if you want
to hear me talk and you just want to
listen to my voice which I know there
are a few people who are like that but
if you're not one of those people then
obviously this channel is just going to
drag you down so I do want to cut the
kind of hey let's you know spend half an
hour discussing one line of code and I
want to make it a lot snappier a lot
more informative and a lot more focused
and you know not distracting and
anything like that so I will probably I
won't script anything but I will have a
plan and I will edit it together so it's
a lot snappier that's one thing I want
to do with the series and then and you
know for those who do care about me and
my personal life and like want to you
know hear me talk about random stuff I'm
probably gonna do that during live
streams because I don't want to
live streaming again on twitch.tv 4/2
churner so that's gonna I'm not sure
what I'm gonna have time for that I'm
gonna settle into this series first and
maybe in a couple months when that's all
stable I will transition to live
streaming but during live streams and
stuff like that is there a better kind
of place of me talking about Who I am
and also you guys are asking questions
cuz I know you guys love asking
questions about random stuff so that's
that series and then the other series I
had in mind was an OpenGL series finally
right let's how like how do you use
OpenGL now it is a bit late coming into
this like considering that Vulcan is
supposed to be replacing up in jail but
I want to tell you guys two things for
as to why I why I still want to make an
OpenGL series first of all Vulcan is
very very early days to the point where
most drivers do not support it both
Android and Windows and I haven't
actually used Vulcan on Mac or Linux but
Android and Windows drivers at the point
where you issue one incorrect or one you
know not so correct
a Vulcan API call on Android and your
device restarts like that's that's how
early days this is and Windows is is
like well whilst I haven't seen a
Windows computer reboot because of
Vulcan it is incredibly incredibly dodgy
right now and honestly making a Vulcan
series right now would be pointless
because I would never use Vulcan in any
of my stuff yet it's way too early
this is just like it's just it's a step
backwards really right now and hopefully
they will because it is turning out to
be a bit terrible hopefully they come
back and make Falcon actually good that
being said OpenGL silsila valid series
that I want to do OpenGL modern OpenGL
of course and then actually so almost
like the beginning of the Sparky series
but I'll talk about everything I write
and we'll talk about good practices
we'll talk about performance we'll talk
about how to write stuff correctly we'll
talk about shaders we'll talk about
everything really to make a good proper
3d game in OpenGL and again that will be
in the same style as this where it's
kind of all quickly edited and unlike
more to the point right
enough about just rambling on about
random stuff although I will have to
obviously give my opinions on certain
OpenGL API calls unlike their relevant
performance and all that stuff I'll do
that anyway but like as in we won't drag
this out too long so that the videos
will be easy for me to produce they
won't take too long and there won't be
too much content in them but the content
will be extremely just really concise
right I'm hoping for minimalism and
concise meant I don't know how to say
that consis 'ti okay anyway you guys get
what I mean right I'm gonna make videos
concise so that's the plan and then of
course going on from that when I
finished the opengl series if ever
probably move on to something like
DirectX and do some like that and then
hopefully at one that's done so in like
a few years or whatever well can will
people will be ready and I can do that
but that's the idea that's my plan for
this let me know what you guys think in
the comments below let me know if you if
you if you think I'm missing something I
know the both of those things C++ and
OpenGL will have nothing to do with
games okay that is one thing that I'm
missing but I think that this channel is
more about the technology behind games
and core technology and writing stuff
from scratch that you guys if you guys
want to learn how to make games you know
you can just look at some unity tutorial
or something like that and you'll see
what kind of code you need to write to
script games okay but the if you if
you're interested instead of using unit
if you want to write your own technology
behind the games you can kind of watch
my videos hopefully and that will
explain everything to you and then you
can kind of integrate them with other
videos for the time being and then maybe
I'll get to making game videos but the
truth is like I'm not that into games
and because of that like I'm not that
keen right now at least to make videos
on how to make games if that makes sense
I'd rather make videos on other kind of
core technology topics and then when the
time comes and we've built up hopefully
a library of code like through these
videos yeah well um hopefully then maybe
there might be time for that stuff but
that's kind of my plan for the year so
I'm not gonna say when to expect these
sometime in February I'd like to put out
a video that's already like the C++
series or the OpenGL series
let me know which one you guys want
first I as I did say I'm gonna
interleave them and I'm gonna make them
both at the same time anyway
but if there's one that you guys
particularly am more excited about I
don't know I think they go hand in hand
and I think I'm gonna basically do one
week OpenGL episode or one week C++
episode one we go up in jail Ipsos if I
lost opengl like that starting would
seal off life probably so that like
maybe I can even tie the series together
somehow so that you know you can learn
kind of both at the same time because
OpenGL of course will be in C++ so yeah
alright anyway that's it let me know
what you guys think let me know if I've
missed anything important that you think
I should put in or maybe I'm forgetting
a huge series idea that you guys really
want to see I don't think so though I
think that's a good kind of start and
then hopefully we'll be able to come up
with some high quality videos and you
guys will be able to learn learn a lot
okay so thanks for watching if you liked
this plan
just hit the like button below that'll
let me know that you guys actually want
to see these videos and I will see you
guys next time goodbye warm